hello and welcome to another night of
chess on psychology
i am dorsa direkshani sitting in a very
weird
sunny position in san luis i did not
anticipate this
ray of sunshine to be this um
direct in my face but by the time i
realized it was a little too late to
change my setup but um sun will be down
soon and i'm kind of
um very sore because i also got
vaccinated today so i'm quite excited
about that
if you have the opportunity to get
vaccinated please please do so so we can
beat this
virus um so
a lot of fun stuff here well today we're
going to talk about coachman i have
two different games ready but uh usually
we only get
to one game analysis so
hopefully we're just gonna do our best
and analyze that and then
per usual do the switch to twitch and
um go from there also for those of you
who are wondering
my desk is extremely messed well not
messy just stuff
here i have the ipad here there's a cat
right here
t here water here microphone here it's
like everything is
just i need a bigger desk but um
please my biggest
um request from you is to participate
as much as you can make sure to engage
with me make sure to
share your opinion because that's why
we're here to hear your opinion
if i wanted to just look at these games
i've already looked at this game if i
wanted to explain to pishi
well i mean he's a cutie guy so never
mind
i take it back i'm just here for peachy
alright so let's go ahead and get
started and i will do my best not to be
blinded by the sun
oh that's a song um
[Music]
all right so this is a game between
coach nelly and karkov
in the world championship uh game 29
in 1978 so it's a
quite a old game and
this game is 20 years younger than me
well i mean i guess older than me
it's 20 years before i was born so
and i'm gonna be 23 soon
my mother had me when she was my age so
at this point in my life i feel like a
kind of a weird feeling just because you
know
she grew a human by the time she was my
age
and she kind of i think she did a good
job in raising this
specific human and
i'm just you know worrying about school
and
grades and stalkers i'm kidding no stars
just cats yeah peachy has two
stray cats all right so i gave you some
little
story of the day too let's go ahead
and keep a little bit more chassis we'll
come back to storage too
because as the day will go by in the
next three hours my arm is going to be
extremely
sore so i'll i'll need help from you too
so i wanted to ask does anybody actually
play this opening
anybody knows this opening play is it
how do you guys
feel about this opening
it's not i mean i this is just one of
those openings that can
transpose to a lot of different things
so it's
understandable if you know
um you don't know it or you've seen this
in a different version but i've got the
chat here
if i don't get blinded by the sun and
it does look weird i agree with that
statement also let me
move my name a little smaller so it
looks
just a tiny bit better all right
um it is kind of a weird like
ready it's not directly because directly
would start with knight f3
um it's just a i want to say english but
where there is going to be a d4 so it
can't transpose to other things
as easily too
so um
c5 and so the thing is
that we think karpov probably didn't
expect
this line that's why he played c5 and
um yeah so that's kind of like a little
surprise that
cautionary probably did to karpov okay
so
now what should happen to this knight
can
it literally has only one square to go
to anywhere else
it would be lost so now um
how do you think white should follow
because i don't play this opening as
lighter as black
and to me this is a quite a weird
position
you have the chance to bring out this
knight you have the chance to push d4 i
think those should be your two
main choices so what do you think
oh uh manish i apologize i just saw your
comment
i am i don't believe it
i don't think that's going to happen i
hope it doesn't happen
yeah magnus is a great chess player what
would we do without them
yeah so let's go for d4 let's let's go
for d4
to be fair this idea with knight f3 is
also possible
if knight c6 then you play d4 and
then you're trying to poke some of those
weak squares and it's quite
possible to play that and um
it's a very sharp line but um
in this game korsnoy decided to go for
d4 ah
take take knight c6 queen oh
queen e4 seems to be doing well hello
kitty
you might be seeing it kitty move around
because he just woke up from his nap
and he's quite confused on where to go
because
he's a big boy and my desk is filled
fishy
okay
all right i apologize for the small
delay
due to a furry creature um
yeah i was gonna i was talking about
queen f3 queen on e4
being on his kind of prime position
because
you know like you see this e4 square and
you might want to immediately jump with
the knight but
queen on e4 has potentials for bishop
d3s
knight f3 knight d4s um
doesn't block this bishop but then
there's no knight f6 over five nothing
is going to attack me just yet
so there i really like it if someone
played something like
f5 which was a game that happened to
corstein maybe about 20 years prior to
this game
um he played queenie 2 and then just
developed took control over center a
little bit better and boom
long castle so this is another thing
that is definitely possible
but the kargov did not want to
get himself into this f5 lines and he
followed by d6
now i want to ask you what should white
do and while you're thinking about what
should white do
um i'll tell you a little weird thing
that has
beside that carpel had already used
about
a full hour for this first 10 moves or
so
we're not even on move 10. so that's why
that's it's hypothesized that he was
not prepared for this opening because
you know
when you use an hour and the first seven
ten moves that is
not really ideal
um alright so
what do you think white should do
ah aaron thank you very much yeah it's
been so far it's been
um quite a lovely new year
new no rules well norwood means
literally new year
new day so
um musa i've heard that too but i
highly doubt that's going to be true
unless he
says it himself and he actually
doesn't participate in tournaments then
i don't really believe that
because he i mean if he if he leaves
chess then it means that everybody can
leave chess and where does that leave me
and i like my love for jess and
you know all right
um so i see a lot of ideas about knight
f3 or pawn f4 and oh my god this sun is
brutal
um so
yes knight f3 is the best way to go now
if you decide to
for example take it to the knight i can
just take back
and that's fine i have three against two
on the queen side
and it will be quite pleasant
to play go for this the d line
d file is faster for whites to grab
the three against two and the queen side
will be a more pleasant end game
structure
so overall white has a better
strategic chance
also if you play something like queen i5
i could easily take it over here
and this is a game between our
dear yasser we all know yasser right
when you subscribe to our twitter
channel you get to hear him laugh
that's actually true that's
a game that was played in a 1980 in us
championship yasser was white
so that was another way that this game
could go however
after knight f3 this game karpov took
now do we most likely want to take this
back right we already talked about
if take we would simply take back and if
something like knight f6
it's still the three three against two
that we mentioned and it doesn't really
help
black so
let's not worry about that now what if
this knight f6
what should we do now what do you think
white should do
we got two options either we gotta
attack something just
as value as our queen our goal opponents
queen or we should move our plane
which one do you think we should do i
will also take
bets on course just generous suggestions
on
when will the sun stop hitting me in the
face
uh if we retreat it might be a little
weird
because we would have to move it back up
again
anyways after knight takes e5
yeah knight takes c6 exactly if you
chose to take it back oh hallelujah give
me that free pawn and attacking the rook
and even check if you play bishop d7
then i'll just move this queen away
anyway
anywhere honestly um
so what about knight takes e4 we take
that
you take this what do you think is that
a good choice for black
do you think that's something karpov
would like to get himself into
and i really do look like a weird
glowy person in this song
shoot the blind somehow
yeah well i don't think the only problem
is kink takes d8
i think that um there are bigger
problems than that for example
right now um
the thing is that first of all we don't
necessarily have to take it over here we
could try to you know take a pawn
and if you try to move this knight well
then you lose your rook
if you try to take it back then i'll
take this back
and i already have an extra pawn yeah
exactly
so even though knight f7 doesn't look as
glorious knight f7 is totally doable
what about all right so let's say no one
might take c4
let's say black needs to do something
else so black can't take over here
he also can't really take over here so
we should move the queen
where should the queen go
um well queen
should probably go somewhere that's not
under attack by the knight yeah
queen b6 or d6 uh queen b6
is more desirable because now
well you have to move this queen and
when you move this queen then i can pick
this knight up
with either my queen or the bit the pawn
so let's say clean f3
now let's say if queen takes if queen
takes then
um this is this is a very
um pokable weakness
and i don't think carpool would like to
play this
very much so that's why i
i don't think carpool would enjoy this
so uh this was kind of like
yeah that the pawns will be very split
exactly thank you
so that's why carpool decided to just
take with the pawn
and um
it's very just i don't know how to
explain i don't want to say sad
i want to say scary trying to come up
with the right board it's more like
course schneider didn't really do much
and the this is move 11 in the game
course trying didn't do
too many crazy things just developed he
had a little crazy opening but
he just got his pieces out and he simply
got an amazing position so
um that's why i think it's
kind of unfair for karpov and that's
something that i've done to people i've
done
i've gotten much better openings um i've
got a much better game right at the
opening
so that's something that happened to
karpov and one of the reasons that i'm
showing this game is to emphasize the
importance of
knowing your openings if you play on
opening you should
have a quite clear idea of what
is happening in that game karpov didn't
or he wasn't prepared for this specific
line and specific game
and we see how badly he got punished
so
oh oh peachy
i apologize for your ears i am not sure
if
you guys i hope everybody's ears is fine
i just had a
my cat has separation anxiety he always
wants to be around him
but he brushed against the microphone i
hope
i apologize deeply for your um
ears okay
sorry for that let's continue um
what do you think white should do why
should definitely develop definitely
castel
king side uh definitely try and start
taking over the d file definitely start
pushing some pawns on the queen side
so you kind of have an idea just how
should we
execute this
why is steady eddy
okay again the bishop of castel sounds
like b3
all right i like that um the one thing
is that kind of have to be careful
because
bishop i like the idea with bishop d3
but
it's better to go for e2
why the the reason is that we might
want to slide is going down bring the
bishop to f3 because
our game is going to be in the queen
side we have advantage in the center
slash queen side so we would want to be
using that
we don't want to have to jump from this
line to that side
we don't want to we don't want to do
that right so bishop e2 makes more sense
because you're not really going
to be constructing an attack on the king
side
at least just yet so
bishop e2
now what
let's say karpov karpov in this game
play bishop b7
even if he tried something like bishop
e7
we would steal castle and as suggested
earlier we would just fiance
that other bishop or not necessarily
fiona keto i kind of want to create
that stable um pawn structure
for just now
um darius yeah i i hear you you are
considering bishop on g2
um good question let's go back
to the initial disposition well my thing
is if you play the g3 just
yet then this gives the opponent
a little um a little some some ideas
but on my king c5 is not doable just yet
but what if like rook b8 what if i start
to
prepare for c5 they'll sell you castile
the c5
now you got to move the queen take the
bishop i don't want to have to
i already i mean i have a pretty decent
advantage pretty decent idea on the
queen side so i don't
want to uh mess that up so
yeah kind of don't really want to
make that change so
bishop e2 bishop b7
finally whoa whoa whoa sorry wrong cats
wrong click castle i apologize for the
little spoilers
um c5 now my queen is under attack
i would ask where should the queen go
but you kind of already saw that
so queen h3 when g3 is also possible i
like queen g32 but bishop d6 can make it
a little
um unfortunate
so queen h3 bishop e7 now
what should we do for those of you who
were lucky enough
to not see my mouse slip
what do you think we should do
at some point we will want to play b3 at
some point you will want to play rook d1
but what's now hello what's going on
i got izadora i got hey buddy
i like the idea of b3
oh thank you
let me ask you is this bishop stronger
than my bishop
oh thank you
because if opponents light square bishop
is
stronger than my light squared bishop
then we should definitely
change them right
all right so let's go exchange
yep this was quite a hard move for me to
decide on too because
i know that i want to play bishop f3 but
just the when of it could be
quite um questionable when should i make
this exchange
so bishop f3
and now black castle
now should we take it or should we wait
for
kind of like keep the stair down keep
the tension
i like the idea that we have this bishop
on f3
we could most definitely take that but
is there a need for it
i agree there is no real reason to take
it just yet
just keeping the bishop where it is
nothing wrong with that
so if you don't want to exchange then
what else can we develop
in this position because there are still
a bunch of pieces that deserve to be
developed
oh g4 yes too ambitious remember
the um vr this is a game between horse
noi and karpov
these are some chess giants that they
don't necessarily want
to you know um
have all these weird g4s
on the board if it's not absolutely
necessary
so what else
exactly this is not marshall
so the thing about um getting a bishop
out is that you have to be careful
because
um taking on b2
can be quite scary and we don't want
that
stable um position of ours to collapse
so if we i agree that we should get the
bishop so let's play b3 first
exactly then we can decide where to
place the bishop now let's say after b3
rook goes to d8 then what should we do
where should this bishop go
i don't necessarily like the idea of
bishop going to
b2
okay so i see a lot of ideas about where
to place the bishop i don't think bishop
g5 is that
needed bishop e3 i like bishop e3
bishop e3 trying to keep a pressure on
c5 maybe knight a4 will come soon
uh i like this now uh black played
bishop c6
and course noise still went out and
played this knight to a4
which is just a little weird for me
because after
knight a4 first of all no take because
aaa8 will fall
so that's not a problem we're not really
worried about that
but after knight a4 now the queen can
just go to c7
i can't really take it over here because
then this
and c5 falls so if i can't take this
then what should i do
oh kitty
so what do you think what should we move
yeah exactly nice yes i think gmp she
also agrees because he's wiggling his
tail
wagging wagging his tail take
take and then rook d1
wrong move brook d1
is this game is all about pressure
it's not about who can take what
immediately it's it's about pressure
pressure pressure and even more pressure
so
what do you think should happen
now what do you think black should do
i don't think black should take this
rook at the same time this knight could
be
pretty relocated this bishop could be
relocated
this rook still needs to be developed so
maybe let's start with the
roxy ain't now um
here is where it gets a little um
new to me because up until here
i thought that everything was normal
everything was following
quite a nice pattern
so
no i do not think that magnus is
leaving chess uh that's
i don't know how this rumor started but
in my opinion it's just a rumor
yes unless unless we see like magnus
doesn't actually play for like two or
three years then okay
everybody can also take breaks if he
feels like he needs a break from
professional chess and he just wants to
focus on his personal life
why not i've done that
so
oh yeah exactly [ __ ] on f6 knight on d4
i like that too so
that's quite a nice idea for what
black could do so let's think for white
so right now we gotta try and figure out
how to develop
well how to reorganize our pieces
because right now
my queen is a little weirdly placed my
rook could be better so those two are
stuff that could be better so let's
start with clean let's go queen g3 maybe
i want to do something like this maybe i
want to go
to e5 i'm just keeping my options open
if knight e4 now we have queen f4
and then queen h4 and this is quite nice
i like this
i kind of have a better harmony and i
kind of mess with your pieces
i like messing with opponent's pieces so
let's say no my t4 let's say after queen
g3 bishop d6
now what should we do
where should we go with the queen
i also think this is also an april fool
april first
or full need
i know no not necessarily queen g5 just
queen h4
winners for normal simple keep it chill
now after queen h4 black plays queen
bishop e7
which kind of indicates that if i played
queen g3 would you repeat
kind of raise that question so after
queen h4
bishop e7 um white
go went ahead and decided to not even
try to play something like that and he
played f3
f3 is so super duper cool and a little
weird
because we want to play queen f2 and we
want to start
poking on c5 that's why it's such a cool
idea because we are bringing in pressure
the kind of fun slash weird part about
this is that
right now black can't even really move
this knight you move it here
hello come to mama you take this we'll
take
that and you just lost the piece um
if you don't go knight to d5 where else
would you want to go
you can't really move this knight
anywhere i'll just pick up your bishop
so after f3 um
king went to f8 defending e7
now maybe he wants to move the slide
around and at this point you're like
alright
ciao all right so queen f2 i'm attacking
c5
take take and queen went to c7
so let's do a little evaluation on this
position because
here is one of those one of those really
weird moves
happened that i never expected to see
um not the literary phrase it's not that
i didn't expect to see this move it was
just
i um okay i don't want to give up the
move so
i'm just going to stop talking now
because i will tell you the move and i
really want to ask it so
let's evaluate the position i have a
better pawn structure
i have a better files i have better
targets
so everything seems to be going somewhat
nicely right
no it's not that we never play f3 a lot
of the times
f3 creates weakness for king so we don't
play it
but there are times like right now where
playing f3 like it creates a tiny bit of
weakness but it gives
squares more to me than to my opponent
it gave me this f2 square for my queen
so now what do you think
what we should do as white it's kind of
a
understated move
ben is always right that is generally
accepted rule
most pens are generally right
no last name needed especially since my
producer's name is ben too
so he's also always right
so no no no no
no guys no g4 let me let me give you a
little hint when the game is going in a
very chill
strategy way we don't want to you know
jump mix it around we don't want to we
don't want to have to
um
g4 looks quite interesting but it only
helps the opponent because
our game is very strategic very focused
on that c5 pawn
and it's very
um i don't wanna i was gonna say not
dynamic game but this game is dynamic
but
in a in a strategic way in like we have
so much space
and okay we have so much space we have
so much
cool cute cat um and
okay i i really wish you guys could see
what i see
um so let me ask you
oh hello hello
um if right now the queens are off the
board would that
help us or not and i have a cutie cat
here who i put my cat on a diet so i am
not ashamed of it
because he was just
he was he was he had some anxiety
because i had a bad week
and because he was anxious he was eating
i was in eating i lost five pounds he
gained a pound
over like two weeks so now i'm trying to
eat better and i'm trying to um
portion his food so if anybody has any
suggestions of cat dieting
not too not too harsh they just want him
to lose that one pound and
be better with his eating habits oh my
god
i'm becoming an overprotective mother i
thought i still had time for this
all right okay ah this is the best job
in the world i sit here i have
an awesome audience i'm doing what i
love talking about chess
but i'm an awesome position and i have
this coochie chat here
i love my job all right
um so
gets him on the treadmill i've tried he
likes to go out and play but the problem
is that
he's too cute so when he goes outside he
has my number around his neck but
even though he has my number when he
goes outside he goes into people's
houses and hangs out with people
and because he's cute they don't call me
right on time to go get him so i
start looking for him for like half an
hour and then someone is like ah
is this your cat yes this is my cat my
number is around his neck
so he's a very trusting kitty and very
people loving so he doesn't really he
comes back he knows the house but
there's so many people who like my cat
so i have to
be around more than time oh my god i'm
overprotective
all right um
thank you thank you for your suggestions
and concerns for
my cat's well-being uh and
yes i gave you enough time maybe a
little extra to
think about this position too evaluation
is definitely that white is a little bit
better
white definitely has the upper hand but
we have to be very very very
very very cautious on how we continue it
and the best way to do that is by
making the decision to try and exchange
queens
so exchanging queens would be a great
idea
darius unfortunately at the end of that
line there is king e7 there's 98
there isn't enough to work with on that
line if the king was on g8 maybe
but in this scenario that does not work
so
queen g3 is oh hello
there is a cat here there are two cats
here
i'm very concerned for my safety okay
um
okay from next time i'm sitting
somewhere else here is too distracting
there's a cat here is a cat there
squirrels running around okay i
apologize i really really apologize
for my love for kids
all right this is getting a little out
of hand
after queen g3 it's a very important
decision to make
because when we do this queen g3
opponents most likely will take
i saw that i saw that a lot of you were
considering clean g3 ideas
and it's very important to stick by your
decision
because queen g3 i agree good idea
but you also have to keep in mind that
take take now
you still have a upper hand here the
rook is taking over this
file there are knights and you know
bishop attacking on c5 so we're doing
fine
nothing wrong with that this opponent's
knight is quite misplaced
also quite happy about that but we
should keep in mind
that black is not completely paralyzed
so black cardboard here played h5
he's trying to stop g4 so kudos to all
of you who
had predicted g4 you were just a little
too early for g4
um
oh kitty you gotta put this big tushy
down good job
now after h5
it's a normal end game where white has
somewhat of a upper hand you know rook
and all now king f2
it's time for the king to come in let's
bring the king
um the
problem is that
unfortunately here um
we don't have that clear of a plan we
know we have advantage but we don't have
that
clear plan so that's why we should be
quite
cautious on how do we proceed with this
um after king e2 black went ahead
and played g6 now
this game is still quite long and we are
going to
go through it but from now on for the
next i want to say
30 moves yeah pretty much 30 40 moves
it's all about maneuvering it's all
about putting pressure and it's all
about okay i'm gonna say
torturing the opponent not physically
don't kick your opponent under the table
but you are putting so much pressure
that opponent mentally breaks the
position
is a little better for you but it's not
anything
for you to you know feel that's
awesome about there's not like a clear
threat there's no clear attack
there is no clear um there is just one
clear target on c5
so right now it's just a collection of
little things that are a little better
a little better that that's so that's it
all right so um here white
oh bishop g5 interesting idea let's know
the thing is that right now with the
king on e8 this knight is just free to
go to d7 and protect
so 97 is going to happen so if we don't
want side d7
knight c3 now i want to go to maybe b5
poke around here
if you do knight d7 i might want to go
to e4
you know poke around here so
all about pressure pressure pressure
pressure we are hitting the mother lode
of
pressure i don't i don't even know if
that's an american expression but i want
to make it one feel free to call me on
that
with appropriate citation all right so
asics to avoid all knights b5s
and now what what do you think white
should do this
this position this was one of the things
that
kind of blew my mind
whoops i apologize for that too long
apologies today
yeah i i expect them to feel
differently after getting vaccinated i'm
fine i have no symptoms just
sore arm same as with all the vaccines
but i just feel very drowsy like i slept
for three hours after i got vaccinated
i have no temperature differences no
fatigue nothing i just very
it's kind of just going to be on their
blanket could could also be that
i'm just taking advantage
of a little vaccination and i wanna
spend more time on their blankets
watching bones oh yes i've been watching
bones i really really need to stop
because um as fun as it is i have my
mcat
in eight weeks and i am not ready i am
very terrified of it
so um
i see a lot of cool ideas coming in but
no after
a6 now the position has changed just a
little bit
just enough for us to go poke back
see this is a this is another
new little poke for me
um now after my day four
brook c6 now we shift the rook to h1
we are attacking on h5
we have an idea for potential g-force
um black cargo flight bishop d6
attacking g3 let's defend that bad boy
well actually this is a good one let's
defend my good boy
knight d7 remember we talked about the
potential of knight d7
and now can i play g4
do you think this g4 is a good idea
do i play on leeches um i
do have a preference for leeches
compared to other websites
i do think that chess kids has good
videos for beginners
so if you are a beginner and you're
looking to improve that's one thing you
could do
so i agree g4 is a little
off but it works it works perfectly oh
i'm gonna have it cat jump
again so i'm gonna move this microphone
i'm gonna do a little prophylaxi move oh
so
many cables i apologize
again for your ears
but i have a cutie cat who
his friend is here behind the window so
he's trying to get my attention to go
feed him oh you took over my mouse kitty
flip this tushy down put it down good
all right so g4 there were a lot of you
earlier who talked about g4
and i think g4 at that time didn't make
sense
but now it does because i'm trying to
open a new file
now i will be taking on h5 if you don't
take it so you gotta take i'll give you
a check
and then i'll take back now i understand
that the pawn structure
looks a little i don't want to say ugly
maybe
unpleasant but it doesn't matter
because black can't really use these
central pawns because if you start
pushing you're just going to open
new um squares for my knight to go poket
what is my cat's rating from scale of 1
to cute he is
cute he's very bossy
yes you are all right so here black
played with g5
now this is a new shiny target for us so
let's go attack that and
again we want to eat free palm we want
to give check so you got to stop me
now i have king bishop
rook and knight three of these four are
quite um active
so why god activates the one that's not
active
and this poor guy over here can use the
upgrade so let's bring it down
if you move the king and now finally
there was a chance that even if you
didn't move the king and you played
something like knight e5
i would still either do dru knight e4
or rook h7 uh both of them would be
interesting to try i mean
pretty much next move i would do the
other one so let's say if i played
knight here you take
check and then i would take over here so
this is one way it could go
um so let's go back back back here
black white king of seven we we have we
expect a knight to jump to e5
soon but we don't necessarily know
exactly when
so um before that happens
we should definitely kick this king back
bring our own knights
now i want to eat your pawn too now you
can't really do knight t5 right
and black plays bishop e7 here
coach knight made an inaccuracy
what do you think should happen here
why to move what do you think whites
should do
i'll give you guys maybe about 20
seconds while we're doing that
we do have a very awesome raffle going
on
with and i believe today is actually the
right the last day
the raffle is when you enter it you
get a chance to win a signed chessboard
of the strongest all-female tournament
um which was karen's cup last year
my favorite game from that tournament
was when karissa you beat
joe and jun i was personally there i was
watching it and i was just like
man that girl is great so um
feel free to enter the raffle um and
try your best well i would say i don't
say try my best
test your luck ah yes i guess that's the
american way test your luck
to win it um all right so
now we we have a clear target right so
let's go attack it
the problem with rock h6 is that it
allows the king to go to f7
this is an inaccuracy i don't exactly
love king f3 because they're kind of
gives
black that knight e5 with check
however i definitely like the idea of
activating this bishop
because right now this bishop just looks
okay it's not really attacking anything
would be perfect if it was in this
diagonal right
so bishop d2 to go to c3 would be
the best thing to do however
after the stroke h6 is just it's just an
inaccuracy it's not like we're losing
king f7 he gave the other check
and now finally corso i did this bishop
d2 so question did the thing
but made the small error because he
could have kept the rook on h7
and kept the king on e8 so after
bishop d2
[Music]
finally black got a little greeting room
played knight f8 trying to potentially
go to g6
and now what do you think white should
do
so this was another move that really
just kind of blew my mind because i did
not expect this when i was looking at
this game
um so
what do you think should happen i agree
bishop c3
will happen soon enough but not just yet
we don't necessarily want to do this
bishop c3
um we would prefer to play something
like this is this is why it's weird for
me
rickish one the decision
to say okay my rook's job here is done
so i want to swing it to the other side
that's such a hard decision to make
let me see it's kind of like the analogy
of like if
you're in like a relationship the
relationship has good as it's bad
the good kind of outweighs the bad but
you know it's not going to work and
you're like
should i cut and run should i bring my
rook back and go to the other side
it's like one of those situations and
more likely than not in relationships we
don't do that
i'm studying psychology this semester so
i have a lot of new things in my brain
too
but that's the thing people like comfort
that's the same in chess
in chess we like comfort we like to hold
on to the plan we like to hold on to
that future idea blah blah blah
so playing a move like rook h1 is very
very psychologically difficult it's not
a hard move to find it's not like a
super trick or super tactic
so work h1 i kind of like this analogy
feel free to use it and
i hope it helps you in your chest and
also in your life
so that's one of those things like
rakesh one very hard to find not because
it's a weird
well okay it's a weird one but because
that's the changes a lot
people don't always like change so
yeah exactly thank you fragrance that is
true
so row case one king g6
rook d1 this is my lovely file i want it
i'll get it i think that was ariana
grande song i wanted
i got it all right rick d1
and f5
so what now what should we do
what do you think should happen now
should we take that or should we move
the knight
i don't think we should take that
honestly i think we should definitely
move the knight
because if we take it it kind of opens
up the rook
and if when we move the knight let's say
knight f2 and i could start considering
jumping to e5 here karpov made a mistake
cardiff played bishop d6 which was wrong
instead of bishop d6 karpov should have
played something like bishop f6 or maybe
rook d6
or even something like knight h7 he
should have started
activating his pieces but he chose the
wrong way to do that
he played bishop d6 now bishop c3 we've
been talking about this move for a while
now let's do it and he
again made a mistake when played knight
d7
something like bishop c7 with the idea
of rook d6 would be the way to go
unfortunately well actually good for
course nine because right now we're
rooting for koscielny right
we carpo played knight d7
now this was another
amazing move by korchney boom
take back boom g4
uh right now the dynamic of the position
has changed
again because white is
not just trying to create
some attack he's also trying to get
square it's not just about poking pawns
now
it's about squares and pressure and all
those things that we already talked
about it's
the dynamic has changed a little yeah
um so yeah basically karpov missed this
g-form
idea taken g4 idea um
he played knight b6 i don't know where
this knight is trying to go
maybe trying to push pawn i don't i
really don't know where this light is
trying to go
maybe bishop e5 would have been more
interesting you take take
take take take and
maybe something like this but you would
still lose c5
so it still doesn't really work
so um after
[Music]
not special b5 after knight b6
now white went ahead and played king f3
normal yeah basically black is
facing some traffic because everything
is kind of stuck with the other one
he played karpov went for bishop v7 boom
bishop a5
i'm poking your knight to be honest i
did not
understand the move of bishop a5 fully i
thought knight d3 would make more sense
but uh there was a time set
pressure not i don't think it was i
don't think there was a super long time
but there was like the second
time control was right around the corner
so they didn't want to
make that kind of mistake so bishop a5
now
black played your f6 okay i'm not gonna
let you check me around so i'm gonna
move this guy around
and okay finally white's position
is very dominating i have control
over center i have control over king
side you can't really advance anything
in the king side you can't just check me
and i also have control on queensland we
know that
ultimately we are going to win in the
queen side because we're going to eat a
palm we're going to push some ponds
and that's going to be the end of it for
black so we're
ultimately going to win in the queen
side but
first we are kind of stabilizing the
king side and the center
yeah bishop f5 also does open d file
yeah thank you for
that so
now black went ahead and played bishop
f6
for almost done with the game we have
maybe about 10 or so more moves
before we reach a super winning position
so let me ask you
why to move what should we do
should white take this hello kitty
sorry i had to snatch a picture of this
the stray cat is behind here
for those of you who have me on
instagram you'll probably see this
picture
oh it's a huge kiss
so should we take it
andrew always take
the thing is when we take it this is
this was mind-blowing to me because i
didn't think we should take it
i thought that taking it is reaching i
thought that taking
well just activates black's pieces
because now you take it
kg4 and
what if check king moves and knight c8
i couldn't i didn't i didn't know so
what would i do after this
now the knight is trying to get
activated the rook is activated
the pawn on g5 could become a danger
so yeah
this would have been better and
good for coach noye karpov didn't do
that karpov just played passive and just
went back
which was faced by bishop d8
bishop c7 would also be better to be
honest because i stopped your rookie
floors
but bishop date was good enough too your
knights now can't really go anywhere
that's that's that's what we really like
here karpovka went ahead and played rook
f5
um rook t4 doesn't work which is so
weird because rook d4 was my first pick
because take take king up now you move
your knight i
eat over here and this is not enough
white has
easy grasp over the position here
nothing there's just not much to do um
white
easily gets to collect bunch of pawns
and start pushing his own
so let's go back to notre d4
and here carpool played jerk f5 now let
me ask you another question
how should we follow right now so it's
white to move
we have a good position because that
knight on c8 is quite paralyzed the rook
on f
file is not also that active it's
cutting our king but our king is good
where it is because it's blocking the
g-pawn
so what should we do
what do you think should happen here
i like getting the rook involved but
remember ultimately
our goal is to push these plants so
let's do that let's push these bad boys
or good boys i guess yeah let's get the
pawn
we are kind of waiting to see what will
black
do because here black played something
like king f7
now i can think about well where are you
trying to go with the key knight g7 97
is not
a danger to me so a4
is not just a waiting move it's also
you have this idea of trying to push
your pawns so you're trying to do that
as well
um why not a3
well that's a good question but the goal
ultimately
is to get that pawn to a5 and start
poking
for pawn on a6 we don't want to exchange
too many pawns because we have so little
of it left
we don't necessarily want to give my
opponent the chance to
pick up all my pawns or sacrifice at
night for a pawn or two
yeah so a a5 and here
king f7 was played rook f7 could have
been also interesting but
if you played jerk f7 i could do rook d5
and attack this guy
so king f7 and here white did another
fantastic just chill super chill
rock d3 this move is so
so chill it gives me a headache chill
it's a good milk
it's chill love i don't necessarily want
anything with this move it's just
i'm waiting i'm waiting next move i
might want to do king g4
i might want to do a5 i might wanna
bring my rook to f3 to exchange some of
these
strokes so it kind of gives us so many
options
so brooke d3 black was a little worried
on this he played jerk e5
king g4 i want to eat your pawn
now king g6 a5
just waiting i want to see what you do
your knights can't really go anywhere
because you move the knight
check and give me that pawn or actually
give me that this one potentially
depending on where you go but still so
instead of knight a7 black played drug
e4
check now after rookie for jack king f3
so what now after king f3
check king e3 rook h4
now i have a clear target for these two
pawns let's go pokem
let me also address that if instead of
rook f4 check king f5 was played it
wouldn't help anyways because we would
just take over here you can't take
because hello
and if you play knight a7 i'll just
bring in my rook
so king f3 york f4
now what do you think well i mean i
already said that
now how do you think this um the
evaluation is
white is definitely better but just how
much
we also mentioned turkish 4 rook d5
going to attack both of these pawns
now what do you think how what's going
on here
which pawn to eat
remember our goal is to empty up
the empty outs the pawns on the queen
side so we can push our pawns
yeah man i think it's at least plus two
as well
because now we take on c5 attacking over
here
that was a very smart choice too we're
gonna go back
defend that guy now again check you
gotta move this one
now i eat here so i have two past pawns
this is also quite a weak pawn
black plays g4 boom check
move the king bishop c7 i'm attacking
your rook
check king up i also keep in mind i want
to play rook f2 and eat over here too
rook b7 bishop h2 i'm gonna keep my
bishop in this cool diagonal no push
no pawn pushing for you now we know that
this position is better
almost winning so it's very very very
important to not give opponents chances
to run away
to slip away to get chances
to get happy to psychologically feel
good about
their one little past pawn so many
different ways to explain this so bishop
h2
black plays wreckage seven now
now we gotta save this bishop so this
was again
this this here was a little weird to me
because we could have just easily played
bishop g3 here but
went to b8 and then went to g3 i'm not
complaining
but eventually we got the chance
i guess we could have also eaten eaten
here but we didn't
correspond just went to rook f8
attacking the knights
knight e7 and just simply a6
he tried to stop it a7
check and i will pick this guy up oh
hello kitty you're right on time for
closing so this was an amazing game
played by
korchny and karpov well of course i won
this game
ergo are tonight topic of course noi
i really like talking about
these uh awesome chess players and
i really enjoyed doing that i intend to
do that for the next few weeks too
so if you have any suggestions i'm very
open to it feel free to let me know chat
or dm me on insta i'm quite active on
there i see stuff
um now we're gonna have our fun segment
of switch to twitch
i want to analyze your games on
leachates
so i ask you guys to
log into your twitch accounts log into
your login to your
literacy accounts and start sending me
games only chess
uh feel free to follow and subscribe we
love
your following and subscriptions i'll
see you guys in about 10 minutes
hopefully less it depends on how long it
gets me to do the setup and
probably feed the cat the stray cat
that's here so
um i'll see you guys in 10 minutes start
following our twitch channel if you
haven't already
make sure to subscribe to show our love
and um
have your games from leeches ready to
share over there
see you in a little bit have a great
rest of your